[musique]
difficile oui quand l'anxiété laisse tomber
cela se produit également lors des représentations lorsque
interrompu et la performance va tous aux spectateurs
les artistes des abris anti-bombes devraient en ce moment
d'une manière ou d'une autre, je profite de toute cette période si
donner peut durer 40 minutes peut
durer une heure, puis après
l'anxiété peut immédiatement
continuer la performance est très
épuisant et c'est assez comme ça
disons une sérieuse épreuve de force
généralement pour tout le monde
[musique]
en principe, je pense à chaque voyage pour
frontière qui pour nous porte maintenant
une grande valeur
parce que nous n'avons aucun droit à l'étranger
y représenter la culture ou le sport
quelques
oh bas, nous devons toujours l'être
maintenant mon opinion personnelle est au top
[musique]